you bring a guy in you tell him
all year long you're my guy you're my
guy you're my guy you're my guy until
he's not your guy anymore
he's not going to take any bullets for
you he's not going to sugarcoat anything
he's going to answer questions and he's
going to tell the truth and it's not
like teddy bridgewater
in his seven years in the nfl has
established a reputation
for being a guy who talks a lot and
says a lot of things that are fanciful
exaggerated or embellished i think
that's the most i'd ever heard teddy
bridgewater talk in one continuous
setting
frankly he's a guy who's very guarded
he's private
he's quiet for him to come out and say
that i have no doubt
that he's telling the truth and you know
this is just part of the adjustment when
you bring
a coach to the nfl who has very very
limited
nfl experience matt roll was the
assistant offensive line coach with the
giants back in 2012 i believe
so it's part of the adjustment it's part
of the growing pain there's only so much
time you have on the practice field
and you've got to to budget it just like
if you're at the buffet line
you only got one plate well you can come
back but there's only so much food you
can fit on that plate miles
and you got to decide what it's going to
be what's your priority and that's what
that's what matt roll decided last year
and i have no reason to doubt teddy
bridgewater
boy mike you got to go to more buffets
if you think you can only have one plate
man like you got it
if you're going to time i mean uh maybe
but like if you're a dump right do you
do double flights
do you have absolutely look if it's
breakfast buffet i'm i'm definitely
putting a waffle on one plate i'm
getting pancakes on another and i'm
making sure that i've got a sufficient
amount of bacon
on both so i don't know what buffets
you're going to but you got to go to
some better ones man
i don't go to buffets because i can't
once i start i can't stop
oh yeah i'm sure that's the only way to
wear that limitation
well well well before the pandemic in
the whole i'm too fancy for buffets no
that's how that came off mike that's no
no no no no no no no
no no and i i always the buffet was
always
very neurotic if you haven't noticed it
was always a source of stress for me
because
back when i didn't have much money i i
i felt like i had to eat enough to get
my money's worth but i didn't want to
eat so much that they had to roll me out
of there in a wheelbarrow so
i i just was always like have i eaten
enough to justify the 4.99
but have i eaten so much that you know
i'm gonna gain five pounds from this
experience so i never was really a big
fan
well that's that's fine look you've just
learned more about me than you ever
wanted to know
perhaps that's true but with teddy
bridgewater look
i think that you're right he's not
necessarily a guy that usually comes out
and says
all that much especially things that are
that particularly critical but
i think over the course of the season
where you had teddy bridgewater you know
not be able to get the team over the
hump
late in games now that is one of the
reasons
why i think matt roll and the
organization
really kind of soured on teddy
bridgewater i mean you had
um you had david tepper the owner of the
team basically come out and say look we
have to be better
at the end of games and when you're the
owner of the team is saying
that publicly and it's pretty you know
pointed criticism at the qb then you
kind of know that your term there is
going to be over so
i mean it's not that there's any level
lost i guess between the two sides but
yeah i don't see why teddy bridgewater
would feel like he has to defend
the practice uh schedule for a team that
he's no longer on
especially when that team kind of blamed
teddy bridgewater for some of those late
game failures
and and you know i i got an issue with
that look they they they knew what they
were getting in teddy bridgewater he
wasn't fundamentally different last year
with the panthers and when you consider
the fact that he didn't have christian
mccaffrey for most of the year
um i it's david tepper is obsessed with
getting a franchise quarterback
so they got smitten with the idea that
bridgewater could continue
what we saw from him in 2019 when he was
5-0 as a starter with the saints
work with joe brady and reach in next
level
and it didn't happen so they write it
off and they move on to the next guy
and if it doesn't work with sam darnold
that's why the the cautionary tale for
darnold is
they're in love with you now they'll
fall out of love with you quickly
and they'll move on from you and they'll
they'll pivot to someone else because
temper wants a patrick mahomes he wants
a tom brady
he wants an aaron rodgers and he's going
to keep swinging the bat
no matter what it costs him until he
gets
the guy that he wants and this year it's
darnold and next year it may be someone
else and if it ends up
that donald's the guy great we problem
solved we got a quarterback for 10 years
and we're gonna go contend and compete
every year that's exactly what pepper's
doing
and bridgewater learned it the hard way
darnold may learn it the hard way
and they'll keep learning that lesson
until they find the guy that they want
all right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports